have you ever lied to your roommate no
that's a lie I'm not very truthful why
would I sign up for this hi I'm Joyce
and I'm Adriana and we're roommates I'm
Toni I'm Julie we were roommates and
we're gonna take a lie-detector test
today to get to the bottom of things
someone could be moving out tonight I
definitely think that me and AJ are not
very open with each other I think that's
why we're able to be roommates
I don't like passive aggressive and she
doesn't like passive aggressive so we're
just aggressive aggressive it works out
I feel like we know each other a good
amount we've been roommates over a year
we were friends before I moved in I
think we're pretty honestly the
code-switch yeah I lie here in there Oh
some things are not true like no I
really don't like kombucha that much wow
I thought we were really close yes
I hate kombucha okay I just drank it to
poop I'm actually feeling really like
nervous about this I don't know what to
expect every time I watch these videos
about lie detector I get really stressed
I don't feel very nervous it'll be fun
to learn and reveal some of my secrets I
don't have secrets yeah I don't know
what you will ask and I don't know how I
will answer well if I know it goes
around your waist yeah this is the whole
thing man how do you think lie detectors
work and I thought it was like a helmet
or something I'm not operating so real
have you ever lied to me probably I
don't know what I probably just the
white light yeah stuff here in there
yeah have you ever eaten their food
without telling them no why what did you
eat
I've thought about it so hard you've had
some cool leftover looking leftovers in
the fridge or on the table and I'm like
ooh baby I mean are you sure you haven't
like actually taken a bite out of some
things that you are remembering but
aren't telling me right now I promise I
haven't taken a bite but my nose has
been so closed
I need the messy one no I know and I
also don't think your messy what I like
how you lied to me
maybe I'm hard on myself and that's what
you're detecting you're rejecting a
messy one have you ever used my shower
stuff without telling me no another
lawyer what I don't but I've looked
inside and I would like to have you ever
used my makeup aren't shower stuff
without telling me you technically can't
use my makeup it would be politically
inappropriate well let's wait for the
results
she failed on that one what he's what
every I don't need to go through your
stuff
John do you do weird things when I'm out
of town no it's a lie yeah what are you
doing Tony what do you do when I'm not
home I don't do things weirdly just
because you're out of town specific
events slide in with your socks
that's cliche if something ever happened
to you would you give me custody every
pack yeah I think you'd be good with
them true I bequeath Remy and Columbo to
you
I'm not a cat person in my day-to-day
life but I really do love those cats
it's nice to have something to come home
to especially when you have a bad day
all right have you ever lied to me
probably yes true that's fair
do you recall any instances there's been
so many times that now I'm just I'm
kidding I'm kidding okay Joyce have you
ever lied to me
yes about what cool I can't really
remember any time some of my body knows
have I ever made you mad but you never
mentioned it to me
no it's a lie I was happy and but he
turned it down
I was just like I have nothing to worry
about maybe now cuz you told me you were
just sniffing my food around and
checking out my face cleansing products
have you ever used my makeup or shower
stuff without telling me I used your
bathroom oh and I used your toothbrush
for you gave it to me
okay let's go that's 14 extra unused
toothbrushes okay guys I don't use a
personal do question have you ever
stooped through my stuff no hmm gonna
lie ooh Wow interesting I have never
gone through your stuff I don't know
what you're talking about but I've never
gone through your stuff uh-huh do you
like me I love you me too
we actually have two other roommates and
so am I your favorite roommate I love
you all equally yes crew great now
that's just gonna inflate his ego no
follow-up questions I think it went well
I she found out that I ate her food and
I found out that she would let me take
care of her gods and that I really want
to use your makeup apparently you know
what I've really thought highlighters
they can use whatever you want I've
thoroughly enjoyed this experience Waits
I didn't know existed or lift it off my
shoulders now I don't think I've learned
anything that new I mean that you like
white live everyone small but it
everybody does that I think it's just
like really cool that we have an
environment where we could talk about
anything and we could just like be
anything our home has good surroundings
it really does and the cats really help
to better people for yes this has
brought us closer yeah let's renew our
lease we don't need to do that that's no
[Music]